i i really like uh
i really as you said terraformers
terraforms is great actually that's a
great moment yeah but like
the story is kind of meh at times yeah
but the action is spot on it's so cool
i've spoken about terraforms before but
terraformers is just
a manga which is one of my favorites and
i've it has like a ridiculous amount of
chapters i think like 400 something i
think it has
it's like
it's almost 30 volumes i think yeah and
it's like i think they just started a
new arc yeah when i stopped reading it
and it felt like it was going to be the
last and biggest arc and i was like [ __ ]
me i think it's already finished has it
finished i think has it i don't know no
way because i only read up to him around
like
volume like 11 or 12. so the concept of
terraformers uh which i i dude i was so
[ __ ] sold on this concept because i
was like that's [ __ ] bad yeah it's
very cool so they're they they sent a
mission to explore uh the moon yeah and
when they got there there was
cockroaches that could just they were
just ripped like
gigantic giga channels
someone had shot their fridge into the
moon and they had cockroach on there
yeah like that sorry
it's like giga chad cockroach i know we
spoke about terraforms before on like
the third episode or something yeah it's
been a while yeah so there's uh there's
cockroaches on the moon and turns out
they're not just any normal cockroaches
they're giga chad cockroaches that are
like super human beings super smart but
have the senses of cockroaches yeah so
this whole team dies that goes there and
you see this right away so it's not a
spoiler um so that then earth goes and
they're like we must do something so
they go and get
warriors or people they think are worthy
to fight and they inject them or in
their dna with insect dna yeah
so each one of them has insect
attributes so one of them is like a
praying mantis mixed with a human and so
he can punch really like lightning fast
one of them is i think they inject it
with like a flea so they can jump really
yeah yeah yeah yeah and one of and this
was an i was sold one of them got the uh
what is the [ __ ] what's it called it's
the shrimp that can like flick at like
all the punches
yeah yeah it's the manta shrimp that can
break clash by flicking the air yeah
yeah in front of it and yeah and i was
like oh [ __ ] i know the men to strip
this badass
and so then they send them to the moon
to go and uh do research and fight back
against fighting chats and it's so
[ __ ] cool because then it turns into
like a political thing because obviously
if there's [ __ ] on the moon there's
gonna be a lot of countries arguing
about what's going on there and who did
it yeah was this here how many how many
chapters they have
22 volumes okay is it over or is it
still gone it's two thousand yeah it's
all good okay
yeah oh okay i need to finish it
three years ago yeah and it was still
ongoing yeah was it yeah when did it end
a couple of years ago right 2014. no oh
is that
i think it started in 2014 didn't it
it's starting 2011. oh [ __ ] when did it
finish
really there's no way i could have read
everything because when i finished
reading it it was not done yeah it was
still going yeah
are you sure it's over
either way you need to catch up on it
yeah by the way i need to catch up and
it was such a fun manga and if you like
one punch man i think you'll love
terraformers i i'm i'm curious how did
you find terraformers because what's the
anime
i'm
what convinced you from the anime to be
like i'll read the manga maybe the maybe
the manga is better yeah okay so
terraformers had an anime adaptation and
it was notorious for being absolutely
dreadful because what they did was they
made this extremely gory anime yeah and
they were like this is great let's just
censor everything yeah but they did it
in the worst [ __ ] way they literally
put black dots and bars across the
screen so there were some scenes where
you couldn't see anything it's literally
infamous because i remember one of the
first screenshots yeah because i
remember i read some performance before
the anime came out and i was just like
how are they gonna adapt this because
some of these scenes are pretty like
brutal pretty gory and then i and then i
saw that i think the famous scene is
where like the cockroach is holding
someone's head yeah and it's just like
he's just holding a black circle
because dude this i i'm still convinced
right if this had like a good anime
adaptation like a solid animation like
not one punch man level but close to it
yeah right
of the action scenes being done that
well this would be like [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah and that's what i was looking
forward to because i remember i i got
recommended the manga from like one of
my friends who was like dude you have to
[ __ ] yeah this is amazing right i was
like oh because could you imagine the
shock people would get when they're like
this there's a scene right where uh it's
very early on so it's not really a
spoiler but one of the scene because
they all the teams drop in different
locations on the moon so you kind of get
like play by plays of where all the
different teams are on the moon and one
of the scenes where one team just goes
out of the ship and immediately just
they see a flash and someone's lost
their head already yeah yeah and it's
like
hold on [ __ ] and i was like right after
she was injected as well
all right here comes his he comes apart
where she kicks us yeah i immediately
died yeah and it's like oh [ __ ] they're
stronger yeah and it's like everything
about this show is so hype
and like reading the manga is like okay
how are they gonna build on this and
they just keep finding ways to make it
more and more interesting yeah it's like
holy [ __ ] and the art style is so cool
like the manga just never stops kicking
off it's it's like permanently just
kicking off it's really popping off yeah
always fight and if there's not fights
there's some like game of thrones
political [ __ ] going yeah yeah yeah and
it's like all right just as we're on the
moon doesn't mean that china doesn't
hate russia like yeah there's stuff
going on yeah it's like it's so
it's so good yeah and it's yeah and i
love how they introduce like i love it
when shows when there's a lot of
characters that it's like this is the
character this is where they're from
this is a height this is their ability
and you're like sick sick thank you and
i can mentally remember that information